i was told there was a surprise for
pilar and i and i am literally reading
this in the prompter i have no idea
what's about to happen i can't even read
that far so
it's really fun and i really wanted
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
oh my god ladies and gentlemen it's the
creator of the momofuku restaurant
it is one of the world's most famous
chefs it's david chang
[Applause]
i
i i
i'm not the only one here to celebrate
the launch of your book we have a whole
bunch of people
hi julian pilar
norman this is jefferson caring here
with the zakarian sisters greetings from
prague in the middle of the night i just
got my hands on your book rebel
homemaker congratulations on your new
cookbook rebel homemaker
so loving the title what an amazing name
i mean i wish i'd go to that that's
absolutely amazing can't wait to cook
from it it's beautiful and i can't wait
to cook from it it sounds delicious to
me
i had
so much fun with you drew just cooking
and making unicorn cakes on your show
but i cannot wait to dive into this
cookbook and have just as much fun we
are so excited and can't wait to use it
i am so excited to read the book for the
book cozy up in a blanket and just chill
on the couch reading and eating the food
that i cook for the both i'm gonna have
two coffees one near my bed santa rita
and one in my kitchen to cook from i
think you're a true jam you're beautiful
and i can't wait to cook with you again
i think the only one more rebellious
than you would be
urbal wilson you're the true level
congratulations well done
all the best
[Applause]
oh gosh
i'm sorry
i really wish i could keep it together
[Applause]
so much about um
life for me is about
the people that you guys are chefs you
know you inspire and you bring people
together and you show different cultures
and you bring everybody together in a
very undivisive way in a world that's
very polarized sometimes
and
everyone who's on that video and you are
people that i have watched throughout my
life like this just watching you it's
like
i can't believe any of you even know i
exist let alone are talking about this
endeavor with pilar who also came into
my life and
made it such a better
life you know because we could explore
and discuss and talk about food and we
developed a friendship because that's
what food does it's not alienating it's
incredibly bonding
um and it's a privilege it really is so
holy cow
wow okay
hi david jake it's so nice to meet you
i'm
i'm flabbergasted and i'm so happy to be
here to celebrate this special day so i
can't believe you're here yeah the
memories that we make based and in and
around food are are wonderful things and
both of our moms
would make us dishes based around
campbell's cream of mushroom soup
um and that was a story that we first
learned about each other
absolutely and so we thought it was like
really important for us to create a
mushroom soup that was in the book that
sort of honored that memory of our
mothers and how they fed us imperfectly
or perfectly yeah and being kids and
that taste i mean a can of cream of
mushroom soup is just like
it's so delicious it's like you know
that you universal um
taste um so this is our version of that
extremely delicious
you can absolutely make it
and if you guys don't mind try this
salad
i just thought how could there be one of
those salads
that just goes with everything that
becomes that side salad that complements
every kind of dish so in the book it's
called pears with everything salad and
the dressing has a little bit of honey
and
balsamic it's just it's that clean
um no-brainer of a salad but it just
does pair with everything it's also a
delicious salad that's all everything's
delicious
it's really balanced it's bright acidic
it's great um i just want to thank
kareem and stephanie and don
and
david chang as someone i've waited so
many years to meet and i can't believe
that we're experiencing this moment
rebel homemaker our book is available
everywhere the books are sold and today
i am so happy to tell you
now everyone in the audience is
[Applause]
i do it's cooking at home
with priya krishna and we're very
excited to have it out in the world
together we're like cookbook twins now
oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]